So consumer electronics has been an
amazing cross industry for the last few
years,
right?
We've seen this tremendous explosion in
terms of digital TV's in people's homes
and mobile devices.
Now people with two,
three cell phones are the types of
mobile devices we're seeing net books
and so on.
So there's been this big growth of
devices out there and that's obviously
been a big part of Samsung.
It's rise,
but now what we see is more of a
transformation to consumer experience.
So it's less and less about the hardware
itself.
It's more about the emotional connection
with it.
It's about the experience of using the
product.
So your user experience,
you Ui,
Ux,
that's becoming more important.
Uh,
the interface is much more significant
than in the past.
Design is a more important element to
doc can feel.
Touch of products.
I mean,
my favorite example is the TV used to be
a big box.
You had hideaway in the corner of the
room.
Now it's something sleek,
almost like a picture you want to hang
up on the wall.
So we're seeing that we're seeing more
applications coming,
content and services delivered through
devices.
So a cell phone started off being about
just talking to people.
Now it's much more about the content and
services that you can get through that
device.
So that's really where we're going to
see in 2010 I think a big evolution,
which is now that now that all these
devices are out there,
we're going to see much more about the
service and the experience that's
delivered design or be more important
user interface will be more important
and all the kind of content that you can
get through these various devices.
Yeah,
it's right that the emotional feedback
is becoming much more important than it
used to be about a device for a devices
sake.
Now it's much more about what you can do
with that.
So what,
what does it do for me as a consumer?
And we think about the,
the experience of using that.
And so that's why we do a lot of
research now to really understand
consumer needs and consumer tastes and
unmet needs of consumers.
You know,
we've really evolved in the consumer
electronic space from being very
technology driven to being almost like a
consumer product or package goods
industry where it's really about how we
manage our brand and how we gain
insights about consumers.
So we have a big effort in terms of
market insights and consumer research,
which I had up here in North America to
get out there,
understand what consumers are looking
for,
what the unmet needs or not.
I'll give you one example which is to
move content between different devices.
So you know,
I was out recently taking photos,
you know,
family for those on vacation.
We get back,
I pull out the card,
put it into my pc and we all stand
around a 20 inch monitor looking at
these photos in the room next door
there's 55 inch tv.
That's where I want to watch the photos.
So we need to make it much easier to
move content between different devices,
big screens for certain content pieces
for certain content,
mobile phone for certain content.
So those kinds of insights that we can
get from the way in which consumers use
product.
A,
and also the things they want to do with
products.
That's where we can really get benefit.